oh my clothes my Gallagher shirt but
it's so tight I had to put on a jean
jacket I make biscuits and you open it
and it pops that's different now it's
time for a Q&A this is Brooks Wheelan so
shy I asked you guys on Facebook and
Twitter for questions specifically for
books and I and we got a bunch of them
that I think are fun let's get into
these questions that we can answer
did you always enjoy the outdoors or did
Brooks get you feeling more comfortable
out there I did not enjoy the outdoors
as much as I do now when I was younger
my dad and stepmom took Tim and I
camping and we did not enjoy it
at all whatsoever and then the next
moment camping was I didn't like can't
be when I was little either I think it
took like booze no I didn't get drunk
out then that opens up a whole new realm
of being outdoors yeah your way you're
supposed to be your where all your
belongings are it's not like when you go
to a party and then you wake up and you
go oh my god where's almost all your
hopefully it's exactly where it was
unless you go to you've lost my keys at
the Salton Sea and I thought I was
picking out which window to break in on
my car they were in the tent I lost my
wallet ui-hwa at Glacier National Park
in Montana
it's a beautiful video of a celebration
of finding my wallet aka with in my
backpack
all the time so grace just found your
wallet right and now you celebrate by
drinking this beer no to cool the door I
had just done the dumbest thing ever in
our relationship and then we went to the
most beautiful place ever they went to
like the main information place and
they're like you've to get in that long
line and reported missing and see if
they have it unless about I just started
having a panic attack and I was like I
can't wait you're like it's got him like
how are you gonna get on the plane you
don't have any identification
mamrie told me that one time she had to
show her Wikipedia page to get on the
plane and
that way I feel like mamrie just does
that you can see suplex by any wrestler
who would you pick
can I choose yours and you choose mine
yes I would say you'd most want to be
suplex by shading but he would actually
dick yeah yeah for you I would say Andre
the Giant just because like I thought
that'd be the funniest thing to see you
oh my god I love it so so much
it looks good dress loose in one outfit
forever what would it be I mean I like
which you guys are are too because we
are to me goose - you have to trade jobs
for a day how does it pan out we have
the same not job that's a no don't say
nothing changes you can take one thing
out of the others wardrobe forever what
is it if we could take one thing out of
each other's wardrobe that neither one
of us ever wears again it was your shoes
that somebody resented why would you
want to get rid of them they're perfect
I've never gotten more compliments
especially in front of you about those
shoes those shoes when they wore out
what are the little like okay well shoes
would you prefer I wear instead just not
cheetah shoes all the time and then as
soon as they were out I was like cool I
have to move on to some new shoes you
got a brand new pair of cheetah shoes
what would you take out of mine your
$1,800.00 jacket is great
$18 it's from the 1920s I bought it in
New York when I thought I was never
gonna be poor again if it gets wet all
right like somehow crumbled let's say if
it's worn it will fall apart and the
$1,800 will be thrown in the garbage can
no I get it
hemmed up a lot I feel like you want
more reality she's TV watching i watch
so much TV only because I don't have a
TV because I watch TV yeah Grace's TV
has every channel ever but I've only had
this as an adult for like the last three
years maybe I know but that's I watch it
all the time
what did what have I given you there oh
let's go outside mentality if something
kind of slightly goes wrong in your day
or just doesn't go as planned or doesn't
go as positive the
this day's done we burned this day away
and we'll go do something that's not
necessarily negative but it's like
that's usually something hand out a part
like drinking how do you figure out what
to do with your life after college last
University well I would say one
congratulations that you went to college
slash University also what degree did
you get maybe go into that for a minute
make some money so you can pay back
those loans long also go into your
degree and find out if you hate it I
would still be in Iowa if I didn't go to
college so I'm glad I like Iowa that was
the way to leave Iowa so I guess the
summation of this is just Kendricks name
ten youtubers me Murray Anna Tyler
Oakley Jake Paul Logan Paul Miranda
sings blue Chester see Oh Lewis sing and
know the Frank I know grace Hovick okay
what's your least favorite aroma that's
sure well grace you shoots poo pourri
everywhere all time
yeah because I am considerate about it
but I know what's going on - smells now
associate Wow lavender [ __ ] yeah what's
the harm in not I'm like lemon through a
garden being like the gray [ __ ] here I'd
rather have that it's only what's your
honest opinion on the reputation tour it
was so fun okay so know we went to town
or so this reputation tour I lost my
goddamn mind
I had a great time here's what I do
enjoy is seeing talented people do what
they're amazing at Telus was incredibly
talented and that performance was insane
I mean everybody was really good
Charli XCX which I found out that it was
XCX I was always like trying to see you
what's it like dating someone who never
leaves their house asking for my future
boyfriend so I know what to tell him to
expect coming I mean this is a touchy
subject this is sensitive I love my
house Brooks loves being in the wild
aka sorry we go back oh I go back and
forth from here just slowly it's good
what do you guys think about my dog good
job if you could both have a fictional
character come to life and be your best
friend who would you choose when I was
little I would really daydream a little
Tommy pickles look like all grown up and
I was like you took away the mystery
very sweet
I always thought Luna Lovegood attracted
her favorite thing the others ever done
I think my favorite thing that you've
ever done is the first time I ever saw
you do stand-up like you were so good
that it like made me very excited
favorite day we ever had was just riding
around in that boat in the Virgin
Islands cuz I you were just like we're
fully willing to be like I don't know
where we're going
[Music]
do you enjoy being a part of Graces
videos yeah I mean do you guys ever
spoil things for the other one yes he
just bought them Balor's mad twice I
didn't tell you if he went last night or
not
so I've learned my lesson and you you
spoil Queer Eye for me maybe I just get
excited posit you see this is what's
about to happen
you know so excited because it's so yeah
and I know I shouldn't do it just get to
and don't ask where should I start
if I want to get into Brooks this comedy
wasn't my album that's I only have one
album out they also can listen your
podcast
oh yeah listen my podcast where I
interview other comedians about bad jobs
but I mean this is my album what's on
Spotify it's on iTunes and then I have
like a company store half hour that's
funny you can watch that just Google ooh
yeah baby just do that who is your
favorite drag queen
ah Trixie Mattel I can't believe you
knew that new you talk about her all the
time
I nobody do Katya RuPaul all of these
are drag queens yes
RuPaul's my favorite because I like how
poised she is okay oh yeah thank you
guys so much for watching if you liked
this video give it a thumbs up and don´t
get describe its YouTube channel because
I'm posting videos I don't know what I'm
doing here anymore but you know that's
par for the course and the Google Brooks
Wheelan if you and I listen to names
comedy also your podcast comes out every
Monday right so does yours I mean
hopefully they know that but yours comes
out also everyone who's called entry
levels to go check them out if you
haven't already other than that I don't
know okay well with that with some
English is I guess there asked us the
questions that we avoid